moment
[Music]
let's see
can you see my screen yes
so i guess you can also see this bar on
the right i'm not sure how to
okay i'll just move it if needed okay so
i'll talk about multiplayer banded
learning and
i'll discuss several aspects of this in
particular
related to whether the players are
competing with each other or cooperating
or
they are completely selfish and maximize
their own
rewards and this is based on joint work
with yval perez
so the setting that i will talk about um
is as follows we have two players
alice and bob uh computer playing a
multi armed in this problem
and it's going to be very simple so one
arm is safe
which means that it has a known
probability of success p
so if you pull the arm then you get um a
reward of one was probability p and zero
is probably one minus p
and the other arm is volatile or risky
which means that it has an unknown
probability of success set on
and we know the prior which is something
new
um and in every round each player pulls
an arm
uh then it observes the reward at that
arm which could be zero or one
um and then they they look at what the
other player did
and they can see the action that the
other player took but
not they cannot observe their reward and
this is going to be true forever so the
the players will never know exactly what
rewards the other
participants got um
so so this is an example of um what it
might look like
well a trajectory so for example here
alice starts at the left arm
in round one she she pulls that and bob
starts at the risky arm
and then alice in the next three rounds
decides to explore the risky arm but
then
she's not so happy with the rewards that
she got there and then she switches left
to the
left arm which is safe and she knows
what is there um
bob however decides to stay longer the
risky arm and
that might be the case because perhaps
his first
pull that the risky arm was a was a one
so he was happier with it
um so uh to completely define
the the setting we have to specify what
the utilities are and the general
definition will be that alice's
utilities gamma a plus lambda times
gamma b
and similarly for bob uh where gamma a
are alice's discounted rewards
so this makes sense we actually studied
both the discounted and finite horizon
setting but i'm going to focus on
discounted to
make the presentation simpler so gamma a
is going to be the sum from t equals
zero to infinity of the
reward that alice gets in round t so
that's little gamma a of t
times beta of t where beta is the
discount factor and similarly for
uh for bob uh so this is the discounted
rewards and
what the utility formulation captures is
that each player cares about its own
reward but they might also care
about what the other player gets so um
like they might if they are siblings
maybe they they do have some interest at
the other
player does well and we can have a
similar definition for finite horizon
where gamma is the sum of rewards little
gamma a of t
where the t ranges from zero to the
horizon capital t
um and now we'll focus on three main
settings so the first is the competitive
or zero sum game
where lambda is minus one so this means
that alice's utility is gamma a minus
uh gamma b and bob's is gamma b minus
vmia so this is whatever a player wins
the other one loses so they want to
have they care about the difference so
they care about who comes first and
moreover by how
much um and an example of this is um
basically any zero-sum game but
when in a market setting you could have
competing phone companies that
where they have a saturated market so a
customer that is uh
obtained by one company is means that is
lost by the other one
uh in a neutral setting which is
actually the setting
that we usually talk as being the
selfish setting so the players only care
about their own rewards
so the analysis utility is uh gamma a
and bob's utility is gamma d so each
player only cares about its own reward
um and then in a cooperative setting
uh both alice and bob have the same
utility
uh so they want to maximize the the sum
of rewards
and so we say that the players are
aligned and uh
a place where you may see this in the
animal world is
organisms that are identical genetically
like ants or bees or
almost identical so they
they're happy to basically do things
that are worse for them so that other
members of the group are
doing well and um
and there is you could also imagine a
partly cooperative setting where
lambda is a half so let's say if
siblings share half of the genes
uh the analyst would have utility gamma
plus uh gamma d over two
uh so here they she she wants to collect
lots of rewards but she also cares about
bob
so uh so the strategies are so a
strategy is going to be a map from the
history to the next
next action to play so what this means
the alice's strategy is going to be a
map from the bits that she collected
the actions that she took and the
actions that she saw bob taking
to the next action to play and similarly
for bob
and we allow randomized strategies so um
and then we can talk about expected
utility which is going to be computed
using the player's belief about the
private information of the other player
and to understand the um what would be
first the optimal one player strategy
uh we'll talk about the guitan's index
which will denote by g
and it's going to be a function of so
this is for the risky arm
it's going to be a function of the prior
new end of the discount factor beta
uh and it will be the infimum of the
success probability
p where uh always playing the safe arms
probability p is optimal for a single
player
so this can be understood as a
retirement value like
if you you have at some point you have a
risky arm with prior
mu and a safe arm uh with probability p
and would you be willing to retire at
that point so that forever from that
point on you never
explore the risky arm again but instead
you're happy to get b
in every round and of course as you
explore more the
the gettings in the exchanges um and i
should also know that when
g is greater than m where m is the mean
of mu
uh sorry when uh so i'm sorry if mu is
not a point mass then we have the g is
greater than m where
m is the mean of the mu
and the optimal strategy for one player
which is facing any number k every scans
will be that in each round
the player pulls the arm with the
highest uh getting the index
at that point um so
uh there is a lot of related literature
which i
won't get to cover all of but i uh i
will try to
mention several uh directions so one is
multiplayer learning in the collision
model
uh so here there are multiple players
that are pulling arms independently
uh they are cooperating for example
they're trying to maximize the sum of
the rewards and they can agree on a
protocol beforehand
but they cannot communicate during the
game and um whenever there is a
collision at some
arm they nobody gets anything whoever
pulled
that arm gets a zero and this has been
studied
in the adversarial setting or the
stochastic setting
and also it matters if the players
receive
input about the collision or not
and uh so there is also work in um uh
economics uh in the same feedback model
um
as in the in my uh presentation
so one is by iaghi from 98 and also 2011
where there are two risky arms
and where the priors have discrete
support and by rosenberg get out where
um they study the same model so there's
a safe arm and the risky arm
and there are two players but the
decision to switch to the safe arm is
irreversible so they started this for
the
case where the players are selfish they
really care about their own rewards
and there is also literature in
economics related to research and
development where the
interplay between competition and
innovation is more than blended learning
um and uh there is so
uh and there are also multiple papers
that study the
the same model uh with the exception
that the feedback
is immediate so the players decide what
to play they don't know exactly what the
other player is doing in this round but
then in the next round they
they see all the bits collected by the
other players and
in the setting so there is no
accumulation of uncertainty in some
sense so
um there is there have been
um observed like free rider effects and
encouragement effects
where a player may explore in order to
encourage further exploration from
others
um and uh and then there is also a theme
of incentivizing exploration where there
is a platform or principle
uh that has a number of arm that they
want arms that they want to explore
uh and the only problem is that
exploration is done by a stream of
myopic agents that show up once and then
they leave so they want to do the best
for themselves
they want to pull the arm with the
highest mean but the principle is trying
to get them to explore more um
and so one more thing that is related to
the paper is from evolutionary biology
where the question is how did
cooperation evolve in animals and in
particular in insects
like ants and bees were extremely high
levels of corporation
were observed and an explanation is that
they're
very similar genetically um
so i'll start by discussing the
competitive setting so remember here
uh the alice's utility is hurry words
minus bob's rewards
and similarly for bob so this is a zero
sum game and
it can be shown to have a value uh by a
mini max theorem due to econ
and the question then is how do
competing players behave do they
behave the same as a one player playing
optimally do they ignore each other and
they just pull the armor that has
kittens index in each round
uh do they never explore um
so the first theorem will say that
competing players explore less
and to make this precise suppose that we
have
arm l um it has a known probability of p
and um armar has id rewards with some
unknown successful btp which has a prior
mu
and we know that this is not a point now
so i don't know if you can hope you can
see the slide
uh so now we assume that alice and bob
are playing optimally in this game and
the zero sum game will discount factor
beta um then there will exist a
threshold p star which is strictly less
than g
where g is the gideon's index of the
risky arm so that for all probabilities
p
greater than p star with probability one
the players will not
explore the right arm also the right arm
is the risky arm
and we can also in fact say that p star
is less than m beta plus g over one plus
beta where m is the mean of
mu um so to show a visual depiction of
this
um so here it's at the interval zero one
uh a little m is the mean of mu and the
m star is the maximum in the support of
mu
uh we have g is the getting z index of
the risky arm so the
diameter here with probability and mu
and there is some p star which is
strictly less than g so that in the
whole
red region from p star to one uh
competing players do not explore so
basically um they are happy that uh
[Music]
to leave money on the table and to play
the safe arm instead
um and here we see the region where one
player explores so one player explores
in the region from zero to g
and competing players may explore from
zero to
p star maybe we don't know uh but
they definitely don't explore from p
star to one so there is the red
interval from p star to g where one
single player playing optimally explores
but competing players do not explore
so now the first theorem shows that
information basically has less value in
the zero sum setting
and the intuition for why this happens
is because the players can copy each
other so
maybe bob wants to explore he starts
pulling the risky arm but then alice and
but then he discovers some gold there
and he's very happy he keeps pulling but
then alice notices that
bob is pulling the whiskey arm so she
informs that he must have found
something very valuable there and then
she starts pulling that arm as well so
um the players can try to hide this from
each other but
uh so tiroman shows that they they will
in fact be more risk-averse
uh and then a follow-up question is so
will they explore at all
um or are they going to be completely
myopic
and theorem 2 shows that competing
players are not completely myopic so
they will
um so in the same setting as the
previous theorem there will exist a
threshold p tilt which is strictly
greater than m
where m is the mean of mu such that for
all p
less than p tilde with probability one
of the players will explore the risky
arm
in the initial round of optimal play and
we can also obtain a bound for p-tailed
which is
so it's greater equal m plus beta w
over 2 where m is the mean of mu and w
its variance
so to get a visual depiction
of this we have again the interval zero
one g is the getting index of the risky
arm so we have p star to one is the
interval where computing players do not
explore
um and now we get that there exists some
p tilde
uh which is uh more than m uh
so this is more than m so that in the
interval zero to p tilde competing
players do explore
um so they explore less but they still
do explore
they're not completely myopic um
so um i will also discuss
the cooperative setting so there i said
that the players aim to maximize the sum
of the rewards and they can agree on
their strategies
uh before play um so the
theorem here is that cooperating players
are going to explore more
um and the intuition is going to be that
basically they
uh because they care about the
well-being of the other player they're
going to explore even above the getties
index because uh even if they
suffer that information will be useful
for the other one so
they they're willing to incur a loss for
themselves
um so here suppose we have again alex
and bob they have aligned interest so
they maximize
uh the sum of rewards and they play one
arm banded problem with this compactor
beta
we have again the safe arm for btp and
the right arm with prior meanings
um and then we obtain that exists uh oh
this will not be big tail i'm sorry this
should be
p hat which is really greater than g
where g is index of the whiskey arm so
that's for all p strictly less than
he had at least one player uh will
explore the risky arm of positive
probability under any optimal delay
and by optimal play i mean any pair of
strategies that maximizes the
total rewards um and to make the
connection with biology basically for
example an
ant maybe could be squashed like if she
searches for food but if she does
find food and that would feed the
wholeness so that could make them more
risk-taking and now to add to the
picture so this is the
intervals from zero to p hat where
cooperating players explore so
you can say that they explore even above
the gizmos index
um and i want to say a few words also
about the neutral setting where the
players
they deal with each player is their own
reward
how much time do i have left uh
10 minutes okay so um
so the solution concept concepts here
will be nash equilibrium and perfect
bayesian equilibrium
so we'll say that uh players i strategy
sigma i
is the best response to player j um
which is playing some strategy sigma j
uh if no
strategy sigma i prime has a higher
expected utility against
sigma j so basically player i is doing
as well as possible
against player j when um it plays the
best response
and um we said that the mixed strategy
profile sigma sigma j is a basis
nash equilibrium if sigma is the best
response for each player
i so that these strategies may be
randomized
uh and then we'll also look at perfect
basic equilibria
uh so perfect basis equilibrium is the
version of subgame perfect equilibrium
uh where we deal with incomplete
information and we say that a pair of
strategies sigma
sigma j is a perfect patient equilibrium
um it's starting from any information
set substring
subsequently is optimal and beliefs are
updated
consistently with base rule on every
path of play that is explored with
positive probability
uh so to understand better the
difference between these
uh it's relevant to consider the issue
of threats and
non-credible threats in particular so
for example
a nash equilibrium might have that both
players are behaving really well they're
taking risks when they
expect each other to take risks but
what can support that behavior is that
one player
if one player misbehaves then the other
player threatens to
respond really badly and so the first
player won't
misbehave in the first place um so
perfect
beijing equilibrium rules these threats
that are not not
credible um rules amount because the
reasoning is that when you get to that
point in the game actually the player
that promised to retaliate doesn't
really
feel like it he or she is going to lose
their reward so
so both are very much studied and so
perfect basic equilibrium is a
refinement of
nash equilibrium and it's it's also
known as subgame perfect but this takes
into account the
issue of incomplete information and uh
now the the question again is so uh
neutral players they
this is really close to the one player
setting
are they going to play just like one
player and they will maybe ignore each
other
um in each round and just pull the arm
with the highest distance index
that's one possibility um so that turns
out to be false
so neutral players learn from each other
and to make this precise
uh so we have again the players always
involved they
they maximize their own rewards this
time and then we can say that in any
nash equilibrium there are two things
that happen
um so first um for every p is strictly
less than g where g is a given index
with probability one at least one player
explores so
and moreover it's also possible to
quantify the probability that the player
doesn't explore
by some time so the probability that the
president explored by time t decays
exponentially in t
um and if we further require that the
uh equilibrium is perfect beijing we get
that the players learn from each other
uh so suppose that we have the p so this
is the success probability of the safe
arm is between p star and g
uh where if you remember p star is the
threshold above which competing players
do not
explore so if the equilibrium is perfect
beijing then every neutral
player has expected rewards should be
higher than a single player using an
optimal strategy
and the intuition for why this happens
is that the players can basically let
each others take
turns uh exploring so neither of them
will
encourage however cost for exploration
and now to complete the picture here so
we can add the interval
p star to g where neutral players learn
from each other
um so this is um
this is for some phenomena that happen
in this setting
i want to say a few words also about the
very long term uh so we we don't know
exactly what these strategies look like
we know that they explore more or less
than
one player playing optimally um
but we want to think about also what
happens in the very long term
uh what what do their strategies look
like um
and this issue was considered by the
ross child in um
in economics so roster um in 74
studied a single-person forum bandit
problem
and showed that the player ends up with
on the wrong arm was positive
probability and
from that he conjectured that two
players that are playing
this game uh may observing each other's
actions may settle on different arms
uh so each arm has some
prior and what was the
kind of reasoning behind this so for
example if a single player can end up on
the wrong arm
this is because he will give up on the
good arm if it happens that he has bad
draws
on that arm so now even if there are two
players it could be the case that for
instance
when alice settles one arm one bob
settles on arm two
whenever alice pulled arm two she got
unlucky she got some bad draws there so
she left
similarly when bob tried alice's arm
armoire
he was like unlucky as well so they
conclude that
they're playing the correct best arm and
the other players is wrong
uh so um in a paper in 98 was a
follow-up in 2011
um ayagi showed that this is actually
not the case
so he showed that when the two arms have
discrete priors the
players will actually converge they will
settle
on the same arm in the long term
and rothschild i should also mention
gave an example
from pricing so you could imagine two
stores
that have different pricing strategies
and each
store thinks that the other store is
wrong
because they have some data that is
different from what the other store has
so so there is uh a different
point of view is that if we think of
agreeing to disagree
there is salman's agreement theorem
which says that rational players with
common knowledge
of each other's beliefs cannot agree to
disagree
uh however the bandit setting is
different so it has
some elements that are not found in the
setting of all my theorem which is that
clarisse keep getting different
information and this
uh uncertainty accumulates over time uh
so if roast child's conjecture is
incorrect then it would be like a
version of oman's theorem for this
setting uh
so um i want to give an example for the
long-term behavior and i'll start with a
line player so these players
maximize the sum of rewards and i'm
going to look at nash equilibria
uh so actually here there is a national
equipment where they do not they do not
settle on the same arm
one player keeps alternating infinitely
often between the two arms
and this is um so this is the
example basically but the the actual
example is here so
uh basically there is a schedule so
bob's strategy is that
he has a schedule so you can do this for
any discount factor so we'll pick some
integer k
and what bob is going to do he will play
um in
the left arm here in around 0k
2k 3k and so on and then he will play
right on the remaining in the remaining
round so you can see what he's playing
with bloom
and now alex's strategy is to play right
forever uh
but forever means as long as bob follows
the strategy above
and then if bob ever deviates from the
strategy and then alice switches to
playing left forever
and uh now they for you can show for a
choice of
p and so m is certainly greater than p
uh you can show that this is a nash
equilibrium so even though the players
are maximizing the sum of rewards when
they're they're playing a nash
equilibrium which has this feature of
non-credible threats uh which basically
it's still a flaw in their
execution and no player can do better
can maximize the
can get a better total reward by
switching you know by themselves
the strategy uh we do so however that
for
competing and neutral players they they
they settle on the same arm so
so if you have alice involved there in
the same setting that we discussed to
the left arm has successful btp and the
right arm has some prior mu
and in any national equilibrium um the
players eventually settle on the same
arm for ability one so this is for both
competing and
neutral players um
so uh and the intuition is that if both
players explore infinite definitely many
times then we are done
um so by exploring i mean that they pull
the
risky arm so if both settle on the safe
arm then there is nothing to prove
otherwise there will be a player suppose
it's alice who explores infinitely often
and then alice will end up knowing which
arm is better because she
is at the risky arm a lot and if she
continues exploring this does in fact
mean that sata
is strictly greater than p so theta is
the parameter of the risk error
the successful ability um and now bob
can't exactly
tell what rewards alice is getting but
he sees that alice keeps exploring
so that means that he will eventually
realize that theta is strictly greater
than p and
he will join her at the risky arm um
so there is a challenge about the time
where this happens because tata might be
very close to p which can
delay the time where alice determines
the risky arm
the better arm herself
so there are some open questions
so one is whether competing in neutral
players always have
optimal pure strategies or if
randomization is required
so we didn't say comment on what
their strategies look like from this
perspective
what about the setting of multiple risky
arms um are there optimal pure
strategies like in the same way as there
is a kittens index for
one player um it would also
be good to know if p tilde is equal to p
star so there was that
dot between p tilde then p star it's
actually not clear they're equal
they probably should be equal that would
amount to showing you
the form of monotonicity in the setting
um
this model could also be used to model
pattern protection like if a player
learns the other player's rewards but
also delay fk rounds
um or you could imagine giving a pattern
like if the first player who explores
an arm can explore it by themselves
for the k rounds after its first
exploration
um and um there are some other questions
like when there are multiple risky arms
do neutral and computing players
eventually settled for group one on the
same arm so
for neutral players it's lesocytosis
conjecture
and finally there is an issue about
computation so i
didn't say much about that um
for example if the players have finite
memory so in the in the discounted game
players need to have one bounded memory
that it grows more and more so
yeah what if they have 100 bits that
they can remember from the past what
kind of strategies would they play
so i'll i'll stop here
thanks amina um so now we're just gonna
open the floor to questions for
uh our three speakers uh i think
yonju is not here but i can answer
questions on this stuff